un moment suspendues dans la douceur et
dans les arbres habiter toutes les
secondes avec intensité abriter le
dehors et le dedans ce lieu est un
accélérateur de bonheur intérieur je
vous suis très reconnaissante de m'avoir
accueilli tel que je suis sans rien
savoir sur mon passé ni qui je suis je
comprend enfin quelle force peut donner
la fois
[Musique]
c'est la troisième fois que ce jeune
homme bien six journées sur la colline
de ronchamp comme les autres retraitant
présent lors de notre tournage il a
voulu rester discret personnellement moi
j'avais envie de silence
de repos de solitude
et puis de nature c'est vrai qu'ici il
ya cette spécificité de l' architecture
de renzo piano ou dans nos chambres on a
une grande baie vitrée et quand on se
lève le matin on a que les arbres devant
nous et
moi personnellement je me suis senti
assez proche de la nature dans ce lieu
alors ça on retrouve pas forcément
partout quoi
assez discrète donc on ne s'immisce pas
dans la vie des autres et pour ceux dont
ils ont besoin il y en a au nombre qui
demande quand même un accompagnement
c'est à dire de rencontrer le chef une
fois deux fois ou plus souvent mais ça
c'est régulier c'est très courant
personnellement je me sens très sensible
à rejoindre à accueillir voilà tout
simplement et humblement sans vouloir
convertir enfin je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire convertir d'ailleurs mais
accueillir les gens qui sont un peu aux
marges qui sont qui ont pu être blessés
aussi par l'église ou des manières de
vivre la foi ou voilà mais qui ont une
recherche pour dire qu'ils ont soif de
vivre quelque chose profondément et dans
ce lieu c'est porteur et moi je je me
sens très en phase avec ces personnes
pour l'heure les églises accompagner
je pense que le fait que nous dans le
vie monastique on omet accents de l'info
c'est tout ce qui concerne la
contemplation de méditation c'est de
répondre aussi un certain nombre de
personnes qui qui regarde par exemple
vers le bouddhisme ou les traditions
chinoises ou autre chemin de yoga voilà
donc finalement ils se rendent compte
que nous ne sont pas dépourvus de cette
tradition et en même temps ces personnes
là nous sommes
nous provoque quelques parle de
retrouver l'essentiel de notre vocation
[Musique]
tu pas croyante je suis athée chatter et
est très
je peux pas l'expliquer mais depuis
toujours très attiré par le sacré je
ressens ici
une énergie forte quelque chose qui me
portent quelque chose qui me fait du
bien et les soeurs qui sont là qui sont
qui ne gardent leur vie communautaire
mais en même temps qu'ils sont présentes
qui sont plutôt bienveillante et je me
sens enveloppé et il ya ce calme aussi
qui fait que est également là la
chapelle de ronchamp qui est très belle
je retrouve ici
des valeurs qu'on a du mal à trouver au
jour d'aujourd'hui dans notre société
actuelle
en 2011 l'architecte renzo piano a été
le premier à signer le livre d'or des
clarisses des témoignages
d'émerveillement et de gratitude se
dessine où s'écrivent dans ses cahiers
les soeurs clarisses les reçoivent comme
des cadeaux elles en ont fait un petit
recueil pour remercier à leur tour tous
ceux qui les ont soutenus dans leur
aventure
je suis ajouté sous la pluie
je repars avec le soleil j'y vois comme
un passage dans ma vie de terre entre
l'ombre et la lumière havre devrait me
permettant de réparer la coke de
recoudre mes voiles donc pour repartir
plein de fois votre vie hors du temps
est empreinte de modernité
une immense vitalité elle nous exhorte à
donner plus à aimer plus à devenir de
meilleurs êtres humains
[Musique]